if you don't think the doctor has always
gotten political
you don't know them at all
[Music]
what you thought just because the
re-watch is on pause and there aren't
going to be new episodes for me to
review for a bit that you weren't going
to get doctor who content on here come
on now
have more faith in me than that
so this time i want to give
my list for what i think are the 10 best
political episodes of doctor who a
couple of things before we get started
first of all
every episode is political to some
degree every piece of art is political
to some degree but i'm talking
specifically about episodes that go in
with a specific political outlook and
point that they are attempting to make
additionally i am going to be ranking
these more
or as much as i am able to on how well i
think they executed delivering the point
that they were making i am trying very
hard to not let how much i agree with
that political point be at the forefront
and i'm i've actually got some episodes
on here that i have a lot of issues with
but i still think they tackled that
particular aspect well or to put it
another way just because i agree with
the environmental message of orphan55
it's not
going on this list oh and if you uh take
issue with the concept that doctor who
isn't always has been political just in
general uh link there to a rather old
video now but i still stand by it that
dissuades you of that idea one last
thing before we get started bear in mind
i am still filling in gaps in my
knowledge of classic doctor who as a
result this is going to be new who heavy
though not exclusive and there may well
be some very good politically determined
and minded episodes of the classic era
that i just haven't seen yet and aren't
on the list for that reason
so
all that having been said
let's get to it
number 10
the beast below
it's funny to me that i decided to put
this one on here because i actually am
not a huge fan of this episode for a
variety of reasons none of which i'm
actually really going to talk about
right now because what i want to talk
about instead is the manner in which it
tackles the idea
of the decisions
and owning up to them
and to imagine
a democratic system
where yes
the voters are deciding what happens but
they don't have to actually process the
consequences of what it is they've
chosen to do if they've chosen to do
something that maybe they do feel is the
best decision but is difficult
the fact that they had to make that
choice at all is wiped from their memory
they don't have to actually grapple with
the consequences of what their vote
means they just get to keep living
it gives a spotlight
on blindness and while it is obviously
as would be the point with pretty much
any instance i'm going to be talking
about larger than life and exaggerated
in a sci-fi fashion
it is making a pretty relevant point
which is
you can't just vote because you think
this will be best and then walk out of
the voting booth and be like i'm not
going to think about that again no you
have to
you have to grapple with the
consequences and if you don't whether
because you personally choose not to
think anymore about it or
in a sci-fi situation you literally
can't remember then you're not honoring
the weight of having to make that choice
in the first place
it's a well-made point in an episode
that again
i'm actually not that big a fan of but
this particular element it's really good
number nine
demons of the punjab this one i will
grant part of the reason it's on here is
just for the sake of my own education
this is an aspect of real life history
that
i don't have a great deal of knowledge
of and i found it incredibly helpful to
have this perspective
presented in a show like this and i feel
again
in my uninformed opinion
it felt like it was presented
respectfully because this is not a
situation where oh
aliens manipulated it they made it worse
they are somehow at the root of the
problem no the problem is people
at its core the issue
is just the people aliens are there we
find out why
i think that's an interesting and well
done angle as well a little bit
reminiscent of uh testimony from twice
upon a time but
i thought well handled and it let the
events and the impact of those events
and the responsibility for those events
to just
land and land on the shoulders
of human beings
because this was a decision made by
human beings
these were consequences delivered by
human beings
and there was pain
suffered by human beings
i thought it was really well done
number eight
the enemy of the world a second doctor
story and one that was actually lost for
quite some time this uh has some odd
things going on in it uh for starters
patrick trouten the second doctor also
plays the villain um in what looks like
a little bit of brown face so not in
love with that but ultimately this is a
story about manipulation and the dangers
of the consolidation
of power and influence and it's not just
critical
of salamander who is the head villain
the people trying to take him down are
also
dangerous and lying and have their own
agenda
even in this exaggerated preposterous
future sci-fi situation
it doesn't forget
that just because somebody is imposing
someone who is bad doesn't mean that
person is also good it allows there to
be nuance it allows there to be
complexity
within
a frankly
ridiculous situation it's well balanced
it's well handled and it does a really
good job of showing just the use of
leverage and political power to get what
you want and to
maintain an image that has nothing to do
with reality and the dangers of that
number seven
the rebel flesh
and the almost people i've always
considered this two-parter to be
underrated i think it's really really
well done ultimately dealing with
questions of
personhood
but ultimately being applicable to
just the treatment of workers because
the flesh
because it's not seen as sentient and
alive is considered disposable
we use it for the job until it wears out
then we just get more
and the perspective on that is is that
the
other people the people the real people
are somehow inherently superior they're
not the fact that they were here first
gives them some kind of right or power
over the flash avatars it doesn't and
dealing with opening
these people's eyes
to what it is they're doing forcing them
to see
these beings that they just have seen
only as tools for them to do their job
as
entities as people and to realize the
damage that they are doing
because any perspective
on another living thing that views it
only as a resource or a tool
is inherently dehumanizing and harmful
and this
again
using a sci-fi lens does a really good
job of examining that
number six
the greatest show
in the galaxy i don't know how much of
the
political elements that i pulled out of
this episode were deliberate maybe
that's something i should have said at
the start i did not go out of my way to
research the specific political intents
behind these episodes because in some
cases
nothing has really been said by the
writers or the makers in other cases
they have said these things but these
were the readings that i had and that's
what i'm talking about
so with the greatest show in the galaxy
which is a seventh doctor story and it's
about a circus
basically
ultimately everything going on
the
pain
the death is for the amusement
of these
gods who think they're above
everything else and that
any other entity
should either amuse them
or be gotten rid of
and i for one do not think it is purely
coincidental that prior to us seeing the
true forms of these gods
they appear to just be a posh
upper class
white
family
looking down
on freaks
and those they feel are beneath them
saying what is it that you offer us
nothing oh
get rid of them
and then you have other elements you
have the manipulative nature of the
relationship between two of these other
characters this sort of explorer frankly
he looks like a colonial era explorer
type and the woman accompanying him and
realizing the painful harmful
manipulative relationship that the two
of them share
seeing the damaging way that people are
tricked into being brought into this
world for the amusement
of
beings that again don't see them as
people
i thought
it was surprisingly deep
for an episode with some very goofy
elements
but i like it
number five
thin ice
if you've seen some of my recent stuff
on the 10th series of modern era doctor
who you should not be surprised to be
seeing episodes from that series on here
thin ice quite a bit like demons of the
punjab does a very good job of
introducing sci-fi elements but
ultimately making it clear that the
problem
is people
there is an alien monster but the
monster is not the threat the threat
is the capitalist businessman who
doesn't care about the collateral damage
of anything that he does as long as it
makes him money and that money making
process isn't threatened
he doesn't care if people die
he doesn't care what damage happens to
the environment he doesn't care about
other people he cares about lining his
pocket with money and he is the problem
the alien
is just there
that is what he is using to do what he's
doing but
this is
the far end of the capitalist mindset
does it generate profit
good
do it
but what about
does it generate profit well yeah then
do it
and
setting it back
in the victorian era as it is helps
remind us that
this mentality and the possibility of
taking things to a very very harmful
extreme is not a new problem this is
a baked in problem
that has existed for as long as
capitalism has and that's not to say
that similar issues don't exist in other
systems i'm not here to have that debate
but
it's not a new problem it was there then
it's here now
and this episode does it nicely
number four
genesis of the daleks
look i i'm not gonna lie i consider this
an overrated story but
i cannot fault how absolutely
crystal clear
terry nation was
in depicting the fascist
mentality
at the root of what the daleks are
and the nihilistic desire to destroy
everything that is not themselves at the
heart of what they do the daleks have
always
always been
explicitly based on the nazis
and the show has not been subtle about
it up until this point but this is the
episode where
you have no business claiming that you
don't get that
to see
the khaled people
to see the military mindset that is
already at work before davos finishes
building the daleks to see
davoros himself very much a mangala
figure someone who does not care about
the damage and who has a superiority
complex that he thinks puts him above
anyone else and again
fails to acknowledge the humanity of
other beings fails to see them as people
the heart of the evil of the daleks is
fascism
and genesis of the daleks is about
showing how the kernel of a fascism that
as depicted
very strongly resembles kinds that we
have had
in this world in real life
led to
the sci-fi monster that we all know
now is it saying fascism will literally
build daleks no but it is there to
remind you
that the daleks came from these ideas
and to implant them right in the heart
of the daleks so that every time they
show up you do not forget what they
represent
it's important
it matters
and it was really well done
number three
doctor who in the silurians the uh
accidentally named third doctor story
now there are a number of third doctor
stories that i was considering and um
including some that unfortunately
haven't seen yet that probably would
have made the list under other
circumstances but
i singled out this one because this
is an excellent
cold war analog
the silurians
are a species
that do have
a claim to this planet
and do not really
want collectively
a war with people but they want what was
taken
and there is this
tension at the heart of it as
some leaders within the silurians want
to find a way to co-exist and cohabitate
while others say just declare war just
wipe them out
and then on the flip side of that
unit with its military approach
believing that well they're a danger we
should just kill them and the doctor
trying to stop that to not let that move
forward to prevent the slaughter
now at the time that it was made the
cold war would have been the very clear
analog where
within both sides
with the ussr and with the western
powers
you had people who very very much wanted
a war you had other people within those
same
bodies
that were doing everything they could to
ensure that it did not ever come to that
and of course in this story
ultimately
peace does not win
and it is treated
as tragic
as it should be
and this
depiction
is very applicable not only to
the cold war struggle
but any situation where the inherent
tension between two groups is so high
that you have battling within them those
who want to find a peaceful way and
those who want to just burn everything
down and to have those entities on both
sides that just
push everything
into the worst possible outcome powerful
then
powerful now
good stuff
number two
turn
left
i don't know how many people think of
this one as a political episode of
doctor who because it's largely um
treated as kind of an elseworlds it's a
it's a what if it's an alternate
timeline and it is all those things
but the ways in which this timeline is
different
are deeply
political and especially if you have
taken the time to
um
get into and i still haven't seen it but
i know enough of what it's about to know
that russell t davies took a lot of the
ideas here
and reintroduced them again into his
series years and years which is
deeply political
but they're here too
because when the doctor dies
and the threats that he was supposed to
stop still come
it's not really about the damage those
threats cause
what left turn is really about
is the way
the nation in this case
the uk
tears itself apart
in the wake
of bad events
and does things that should not be done
and using tragedies to justify them
it
matters
that when
a family
of
immigrants
is being carted away
in a truck
to a camp
a work
camp
that
wilf
who
was a veteran
sees them get packed in and driven off
and says
it's happening again
because in trying times when the world
feels like it's coming apart
things that should not ever happen
to some people start to look justified
it looks like a way to regain control
when in reality you are simply
committing
atrocities and things that should not
happen
again treating people as something
other than people
the dehumanizing
and the messages about how
a quote unquote civilized society treats
the most vulnerable
of its populace
when the chips are down
and they want somebody to blame
it's hard to argue
with the effectiveness and the political
intent behind that
and finally number one
oxygen
i don't think too many people were
expecting there to be anything else at
the top but oxygen
is a
fantastic
episode with my favorite doctor peter
capaldi from my favorite series of his
run series 10. like thin ice this is a
critique of capitalism and it actually
is a brilliant complement
to thin ice which looks at the past and
how that mentality already existed back
then and then flings us into the far
future and shows the extreme
technologically buoyed end game of that
mentality what your employers are
telling them to do and what would that
be
save the oxygen that you are wasting you
become inefficient
once the workers are no longer
productive enough
just kill them and bring in new ones
everything is monetized
you have to earn your right
to breathe
and people can claim that this is an
absurd exaggeration but
even if it is even if i were to grant
that which honestly
i'm not sure i would
but
even if i do grant that
so what
sometimes the best way to make a point
is to take it to its logical extreme to
highlight the problems with that system
with that methodology with that mindset
highlight them at their most magnified
and have people realize okay
corporations aren't charging us to
breathe
but
they are
charging us and controlling a great deal
of vital resources we need to just live
and maybe to a greater extent than is
good or healthy for anybody other than
them
so even if you think this exaggeration
is so far
from the reality that
that'll never happen doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if it would never happen
because the mentality behind
the corporation
that
decides to just get rid of its workers
when they aren't doing a good enough job
that mentality exists now
and even if it's not resulting in people
suddenly having their oxygen taken away
from them it is at the heart
again of capitalism of large corporate
mentality especially
and this
it does what socially conscious sci-fi
is built
to do
take something going on extrapolate it
out to its most extreme
in the future with foreign technology
and make it clear the problems that this
blown up version is showing you
are real now
even if on a smaller scale i think it is
a masterfully done piece of political
entertainment and it's my pick for the
best political episode of doctor who
what are your picks for the best
political episodes whatever they are
drop something down the comments and
let's talk about it i've got a patreon
there's a link up there rewards for
every tier you can see videos up to a
week in advance also you can get your
name in the credits you're gonna start
seeing those in just a minute but even
if you're not able to do that there's
also youtube memberships with some other
perks but even if you can't do that like
share subscribe helps me out helps me
battle the freaking algorithm
but even if you can't do that
it's okay
because at the end of the day
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]